we then when the whole hog cut the
strings and dunked the chicken legs
completely in the acid and that was
really fascinating the chicken leg in
HCl and in sulfuric acid just went a bit
more yaki if you like the solution got
darker color and the color is probably
due to the pigment the myoglobin
reacting with H+ from the acids so it
just becomes more light absorbing
but with HF the chicken leg
first of all visibly starts looking
almost like shredded cooled chicken meat
and it goes dead white before it looked
a sort of yellowy color and it looked
like corpses one imagines corpses to
look this the meat went absolutely white
to add a glove but skins come up
and then at the end because Neil had to
neutralize these you can't put highly
acid chicken legs away in the waste he
dropped them into solution of carbonate
I think potassium carbonate where the
residual acid reacts with carbonate to
produce carbon dioxide as the chicken
legs were dunked into the carbonate
solution they started bubbling now the
first thing that was interesting is the
leg that had been in sulfuric acid which
had been rather more buoyant than the
other legs it didn't sink as well in the
sulfuric acid but once it got in the
water it sank like a stone
first the HCL and the HF both stayed
near the top the HF really bubbled much
more suggesting that the acid could
penetrate much better in the meat I mean
after all a chicken's leg is not just
meat
it is highly structured muscle so that
the chicken can run around and try and
escape the pharma but all of that
structure has been destroyed in the case
of the HF with the sulfuric acid and the
HCL there has been some destruction but
the meat is still recognizable as meat
but essentially with HF it is gone
completely white and there is more
bubbling because this white mass is now
like a sponge and can just absorb much
more acid so it's a bit like the chicken
leg has turned into a paintbrush I think
it's really interesting experiment in a
way it's far more interesting that we
expected I mean we went home really
disappointed you know we'd spend all
this money on the chicken legs nothing
happens but in the end I think we learnt
a lot more about the chemistry than we'd
expected first of all that HF seems to
destroy the pigments in meat very
quickly and also what is quite
interesting and you don't normally see
is that the structure of meat when you
remove the pigments is absolutely white
almost like cotton wool or something
like that so I think in the end it's
been quite a good lesson I think it's
important to stress that this is a
demonstration not an experiment we
didn't have a hypothesis beforehand
except that it might dissolve but it did
have at least the beginning of the
scientific method in that we had to
control Lakes so that we could
noticed differences if we just done the
leg in HF by itself we probably would
have missed some of the most interesting
features so the moral is think what
you're doing before you do an experiment
you might learn a lot more